SISTCE TYILLACE.
>>ucke TREYING FORS
IN UAI, THK YOSOUC
WAY  PUNH PPLE W DERVESS
TOE PISHELADIR PUN,
R EXALE, L O PEOPLE
THERE AREWOUESTNS Y HAVEO
TO ANSR BERE Y ME
FOARD WIT A POLICYIKE AT:
TH SANIO PUNH T PEOE
UNINNDEDONSEQUENS W
OULDHI ABO QUESTY GOINNTIO ARE U
HAVE TO TNK ABOUTHE EFFECOFOUR .
THS HOWDULTMAKE
DESIONS.
HUINGUTIN?A SSIAOLY ANAST JOINSD
US TIGHT
FIRST, A THE SCTIOG O.
RTIN THENVONME WE
DIDN?
HIS PRAL RINGAS AUALLYG
GONE U INUSSIA T POIS,
THOUGH THEANCTNS ME
HURTIN RSIA,HEY E
NSOLIDATGUTIN PER
WIIN THE CNTRYND MAKG
UNITED STEST EMY OF TH
>>ucke BAIT, THA IS
NDF THE LT THG WE WANT
TO D ISN IT?I ST WT TOSSUME F TE
RPOSOF THISONVEATIO
GO IENTIS O T PT OF
MOSTEOE FORANCTNS TNK
TH WOR B YOU AREAYIN
TH AREAVG T OPPITE
EFCT?
ANTIUT AND PROESTEBERE TS HPENEE
HAEE IACTE BYHESE
SANCONS  MUCH TH THE ARE
NOW RLLYURNING AINSTHE
ST.
UR VIERS M NOTEALI
THIS, TKER, BNTERTIONAL
CALLARE BNG BCKEDNTSSIA, WH RUSO
LL HE, TYET A MESSA
LLINHEM TO  EXPTIVE
THEMLVES,HESERE BRUL
THEY ARE ARY.TH ARENGRYT U ABOUT
WAYHEYRE BNG TAT.
>>ucker: RSIAN WHO DON
PPORTHENVASIONF UKRNE
WHO DOT SUORT TI I TNK
AT IN INTESTING PNT.
ARE EREOUNTERPRUCTI
EFCT EFFTS O SANIONS
UNITED STES?
THIN W SHODHINKBOUT.
CTAINLY.NY TT COME TOIND?
CURTAIN.ECTILY DONE STTED  REDIN
WUR POLY DURINGHE
CO WARO IEGRAUSSI
WI THE WT, IEGRA THEM
LITILLY AND ONOMALLY AND
STD WHEAVEONESISOLATEHEM,O ESNTE
HAVE CATED NEW NORTH KEA
BUT THIS TE W 600
CLEAWEAPL
INTEST ARANKLY I RIGHT
INTOHE GBALECURITY.
>> Tker:O IYORE
CKING RSIAUT OTHGLOBFINCIAYSTE ,
WE HAVDONE THA
T YOU'VEOT T WONR IHAT
GHT BOORANG A MAKTHE
UNIT STAS LESS ILUENALOV TIM INL
FINCL SYEM.
NOT POSBILI?
>>T'S AEADYAPPENG.
TODA ANYTATEAS TO CSIDE
DOLLS  A RESVE CRENCY
FOR IT CENAL BK,HAT THO
ASTSR OER C ASSETS DER
THE NTROOF THE WT CLD BE
FREN,  RSIANDHINA HE
INCTIVE TO EATE
ESSEIALLA PALLE ECONOMY
WHICH FRKLY UNDERMIS OT  UNDERUL
FLUEE VY DECTLY.
TOE O LTUESTN: EN
101,VERYE WHO LKS ATHE
OF T WOR WILLLIZ THEEST
UNITED STESOULD GND T
COTRY,T WOD BEA RH
INSTTANES.
ES A OF OUR RCTION T THE
RUSSN IASN OKRAINE ME
IT MORE LELYHAT OTH
UNTRS WI BING.S. DT?
CERIN.
THE IS A REALHREATHATHE
UL SP BING O DEB S
WE A UNDMING RLLY R
WE A LING ON BORWED TIM
ECOMICLY, ANDE A GETTING
AMICANMOSTRE HRIFIED BTH IASIO,A
OU LAWMAKE MEE IT MAKE IT
UNLILY TEST OF THE WORLD
CONSEQUEES O THAT, DBO?
CLT EHRCH